thank you
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we're very
careful boys today we're talking about
how your parents disciplined you of
beating their [ __ ] asses okay all of
us really had parents that did that yeah
my mom used to beat the brakes
is their mom the violin type or the
creative type or the like uh she was the
old silent treatment type
she was the violent type but then there
was a point where she kind of stopped
doing that and then just would like nag
us to death what's the worst ass beating
you ever got foreign
there's a lot I don't think there's one
that was like really hard it was just
the sustained efforts across the board
like she just was very consistent she
went back to her corner and her coach
was like Hey [ __ ] [ __ ] what was your
move she would just grab anything like
she would grab I remember oh I was just
like whatever you gotta do it let's do
it you gotta take me up dude you gotta
[ __ ] I was vaselineing her eyes yeah
yeah yeah
you know those Hot Wheel tracks oh yeah
oh smack me with those hurt she was
smack him with anything shoes [ __ ]
belt hangers you know just like [ __ ]
anything do you think she was I was [ __ ]
I would always be a little I was alone
because I was [ __ ] yeah yeah I was no
I was definitely not [ __ ] you was a
[ __ ] boy yeah just like you know all the
stories that we talked about me writing
[ __ ] Margaret oh yeah just like I
would just do the greatest you just did
dumb weird [ __ ] because I was I was the
youngest and then I was kind of like by
myself because my older sisters would
always be together so I'd always be like
experimenting I would always just be
[ __ ] around I used to put things in
the electric sockets
oh yeah you need to be taught not to do
that you need to be disciplined dude she
just [ __ ] smacked me up and then she
would just yell at me all the time
because did you ever feel love from her
though or does it just yeah like
like I think they're actually just so
[ __ ] mean to not even want her to be
my mom anymore no because I think there
was a point in me that like I knew that
I was like [ __ ] around but then as I
get older my sisters were like look
you were like a good kid you were you
weren't like that crazy but also like I
think my mom just got a little carried
away a little bit certain things of
course yeah it was a different time like
it's not like
I think she had the tools to not do that
she would have but I think there was a
lot of things stacked against her at
that time you know like she wasn't
really getting that much support from
like my dad as far as like parental
stuff so she was like it was her three
kids so she would kind of like rely on
my sisters to like discipline me a
little bit too she's pushing it to limit
she pushes to the Limit dude she's
making deals she's shaking hands
well I'll tell you the time
I disciplined my brother and it was my
fault oh [ __ ] and you was laughing in
the back now huh oh you regretted it huh
oh god let's go all right so my mom
would always hide like the treats and
candies and stuff in different spots of
the house and I was the only one out of
the family that would always find it and
so like one night I found the new stash
and I like brought it to my brother's
room I was like look what I found he's
like what I was like yeah let's eat it
here in your room and so we ate all the
snacks and we had a good time and then
we I was like yeah let's just hide the
rappers here in your room and uh he's
like all right yeah where else are we
gonna hide it we're like oh six seven
um older brother younger brother older
you're older yeah it's his fault then he
should have known better he should have
he should have buried it outside that's
actually not my fault or he knew better
he was protecting you really well yeah
uh she sounds very good just wait till
the end okay let's hear the rest you're
a detriment um and so one day my mom
went into my brother's room to like I
guess like clean and organize his room
and found all these rappers and was like
so you're the one that's stealing and
like like made this whole thing yeah
well I guess
um and so spider's Keepers you're right
that's what I'm saying and uh so she uh
took all this candy and went up to my
brother's room like so you like candy
huh made him eat it like all of it
trying to like so you like candy this is
how you're gonna like stop eating candy
it's like a pit my ride punishment right
and then so like he's like crying he's
like eating the candy he's like yeah but
please the one that found I was like I
don't know what you're talking about oh
you did that like my brother till this
day I was just like and that's when I
knew I was like you're dead
wasn't in the mood for candy yeah I was
just like I don't eat candy yeah I don't
like it I'm like damn dude she's like
why would the rappers be in your room if
I ate them wow exactly like that's shady
exactly but that's that's his fault for
trying to [ __ ] take you down with him
yeah yeah yeah but like yeah if you try
to eat this pile of candy and just like
your stomach's hurting like at this
point you're just like I don't even want
to look at another piece of candy but if
he wasn't a piece of [ __ ] he'd been like
I am a hungry boy
I know we have a you know a very strict
like no writing everybody I'll roll but
I do feel like siblings are on a totally
different plane they wrap me out all the
time right it's just like it's siblings
like you just sometimes riding your to
your to your parents about like trivial
[ __ ] is it because it's like it's like a
safe space it's kind of like it stays
it's within the family or whatever I
just think his siblings just have
different rules with each other you know
what I mean it's like I [ __ ] don't
like you but I [ __ ] have to love you
always yeah those people are either like
best friends or Worse enemies their
siblings have each other's back rally
and next the guy in the crowd is like
I'm not buying it
serious I remember my sister betrayed me
dude this is she betrayed she's my
oldest strong words betraying she was
like this is when I realized like as
like as I got older I was like I can't
trust my sisters dude I cannot trust you
but now you can't trust them low-key nah
low-key uh more like hiking now yeah
yeah I was in high school I came I was
going out with my buddies and they were
like they want to smoke some pot and I
was so I was like 17 or something like
that we're driving around and we hot box
somewhere right me and two other homies
I drive back they drop me off and I just
smell like reek of pot because my
dumbass was like we rolled the windows
down it's all good you know so yeah well
we were like five minutes away from my
house so it's like not that long of a
drive I come back smell like pot my mom
was like were you smoking and I was like
no I wasn't I was just in the car you
know I just [ __ ] anything to get them
off me and I was baked to [ __ ] so I was
just like just survive just survive so
she's yelling at me all [ __ ] day and
she's like yeah I was I was getting it
for sure and then my sister comes into
me the next morning she's like you okay
and I'm like yeah she goes were you
smoking pot
and I was like she's like I'm not gonna
tell Mom
that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
I was
I was I was smoking pot but she's like
all right whatever blah blah blah next
day my mom sits me down over eating
breakfast and she goes
so uh Ashley told me you were smoking
oh they're friends
yeah I got a guy and I was like [ __ ]
up that's double cross right there yeah
bro [ __ ] oh that [ __ ] and then ever
since then I have a complex of like I
ain't telling you this yeah don't tell
her [ __ ] Bro [ __ ] [ __ ] nothing don't
tell her [ __ ] no wonder you didn't tell
the [ __ ] for like 24 months on JK I got
trust in you bro
and you guys are all the same age as my
sisters so I'm just like I don't trust
nothing yet dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's kind of [ __ ] up
um so uh not any specific moment but for
some reason burden in my memory I
definitely remember my mom my dad have
two separate moments that definitely
stuck with me one it's so funny talking
about parental abuse one
she had this [ __ ] feather duster damn
father dusters [ __ ] hate the feather
duster but there was one time where
she's got so pissed at me I don't
remember what it was for but she's like
go to living room pull your pants down
along the floor usually I get hit with
the feather duster like in passing did
you lay down with their penis up
stupid you're like I don't know what Mom
wants
I know
that's how you get her to stop but
that's risky though what if she doesn't
stop
Bart's like oh I know how I'll get her
it's a bird move double down she didn't
say which way yeah just lay down pull
your back on and lay down all right I
lay a massage get hit with the feather
duster obviously it hurts because he
like welts up [ __ ] yeah dude but like
usually I always get hit like either on
the arm or even on the butt but with
your clothes on it's different when you
have to like submit to like the full day
when you have to lay down on the floor
and bare your ass and then she's doing
more than one strike how old were you
I might have been like 10 or 11. yeah I
just remember I [ __ ] was not walking
straight for a minute 17. that's what I
was hoping I was 32.
um so that that was that one all [ __ ]
feather dusters what did you do I don't
even remember I only remember the
punishment you blacked it out yeah
probably but I don't think I'll ever
have a feather duster in my house I just
it no oh too dramatic because I'm I'm
going to grab it I'm going to whoop
somebody with it that's all I know what
I don't know I've only been taught one
thing it's not that efficient that's why
we don't dust you know what I'm saying
I've never seen it clean uh allergies
are an all-time high in here and [ __ ]
second one was I don't know if I
mentioned it here before for some reason
I feel like I have but there was this
one time where again I don't really
remember what I did I definitely was
just like embarrassing my parents in
front of their friends they had guests
over I like tried to turn on the [ __ ]
music and it like blasted the speakers
with the volume way too high to not use
it so it just blasted music but I got
pissed at me because it's like you know
he's got guests in the living room he
sends me to my room what the heck now
get appears start stopping upstairs
right yeah yeah and then I tried to
[ __ ] slam the door but it was one of
those things where like the second the
momentum happened was the second regret
yeah I was like boom I didn't mean to
slam it and then I just oh [ __ ] I hope
this is on patreon
my door Slams on patreon you hear the
[ __ ] footsteps yeah you hit like I
hear my dad just like uh just wait and
just [ __ ] hear the footsteps and he
comes out I think he dismissed his guest
by the way I think it was at that level
oh that's serious yeah he like told him
to leave and because it took a minute
because I remember like waiting and
sweating by myself for like three
minutes [ __ ] had them leave stop
coming upstairs I can't open the door
started yelling some gibberish and then
he's he sat me on the bed and slapped me
this man this is gonna be something
Social Security don't come from my
parents I love him
like the statue of limitations Social
Security yeah there's a secret service
Social Services API FBI and [ __ ] uh
IRS
Ira from Ireland
so yeah please don't arrest me can you
just not go and also don't cover them
and then YMCA chill
um no but I remember him slapping me and
things he always said I always got
slapped yeah but this time he like
stopped me a couple times in my a loose
baby tooth came out so and again again
it's a loose baby in retrospect I'm like
oh it's probably gonna come out in but I
look it's crazy in the moment though it
looks bad when you start having blood
and then finally my mom who usually is
like yeah again is that you know he's
just staying staying in the bed yeah fun
is the first time ever in my again this
just burned in my mind she's finally
holding his arms back as he's trying to
[ __ ] like yell at me and slap me or
something
oh [ __ ] no and I just remember that
being the craziest thing and then you
looked up and you're like that's all you
got [ __ ]
no I was scared for like six more years
after I got like 12 more of those babies
I was a [ __ ] good boy I didn't hear
no [ __ ] Bell
here's how dumb it got for me and again
uh I know for a fact they're way crazier
situation than people have got way worse
like parental stories now that I'm an
adult
but I do remember this is so
embarrassing
um it was time to write College [ __ ]
essays and then you know I didn't know
what to [ __ ] right about about Bob
bullshiting you so then one time and I
have an older sister so you know
thankfully like high school writing
essays for to get into college okay and
then once you know everybody's like yeah
just write about something stand out
yeah make sure you stand up oh my God
yeah that's always what people say yeah
so you know I'm writing and then I start
for whatever stupid ass kid reason I
start integrating that story in oh no
trying to like I'm like oh this might
make me stand out maybe they'll [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah this is unique this is
part of my childhood and I'm like I'm
telling myself Aaliyah can you read this
or actually like reads it she's like no
she's dreaming me so I rewrote my entire
essay that didn't include any parental
fighting up your feelings good job and
you didn't stand out yeah yeah yeah
worst of all for me you didn't stand out
I got rejected to be fair most Asians
were probably writing about their
parents beating them my my most I think
weirdest situation I got my ass beat was
uh so my mom's been on like a crazy
nutrition Tip since I was a [ __ ] baby
right like so even with like regular
instead of going to like Western
medicine if I ever got sick or even if I
sprained my wrist we're going to some
acupuncturists or Eastern medicine place
where we're [ __ ] boiling scorpions at
home and drinking like just like [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] right so even when it came to
regular food like
back in the 90s she's we had this
Panasonic [ __ ] uh bread maker because
she just felt like bread was so like
lack nutrition at Sonic so she had this
bread maker where like she would like
cut like like put beets and [ __ ]
papaya and mangoes and [ __ ] and it
should bake it into this loaf of bread I
think she's like she probably saw raisin
bread and go I know I'll have other
fruits so we have this [ __ ] bread
that she would bake and she would slice
it and then like when you hold it up to
the light it looks like a stained glass
window like it's just [ __ ] the nasty
idea of holding bread up to the Lane I
know exactly what we're talking about
because you're a [ __ ] kid and you're
like why can't I just have Wonder Bread
like everyone else I got this [ __ ]
fruitcake and when you [ __ ] uh yeah
it's like fruit cake my mom did that too
with apricots yeah and when you slice
bread by yourself it's [ __ ] up like
because you need the serrated knife yeah
it's like this thick at the bottom this
thing at the like your sandwiches are oh
I see what you mean my mom's food is
nasty as [ __ ] all of like our rice is
like the super red and like dark Bean
purple oh yeah so when you're in school
you're trying to trade your food with
other kids like no I just take it I just
dump it I just take it you try to make
it appealing like look at the stained
glass bread you want it for that PB J
it's so nasty right so it's a version
parental discipline she put fruit in my
bread
couple days my mom will be like here's
your food and I'll look at him like and
she's like when I come home this had
better be done you know so like days
like spring break we got like the whole
week she would make food like every day
and then when she comes home she wants
me to be like [ __ ] all nutritious and
[ __ ] and eat all that stuff so when it
came to
um lunch time I'll take the food out and
I'm like
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] am I gonna get rid of
this food if I throw in the garbage you
can see in the garbage by putting the
garbage disposal she's gonna see in the
garbage disposal I don't know what to
[ __ ] know about so I go out the
backyard and I just go like this
over the wall it chucked it over the
wall over the wall what's on the other
side who knows this old Korean lady I
don't even knows this old Korean lady I
don't know if you remember then that's
not good for the story yeah yeah oh no
so first day I'm like oh I push it
[ __ ] works second day works
[Laughter]
then one time I go like this and then
she goes hey so it's a Jew that's doing
it I'm like oh [ __ ] I ran back inside
and I'm like hiding underneath the
window still like this and then she's
like I know somebody's there I'm gonna
come here when your mama comes home or
whatever and I was like oh [ __ ] oh no
that day like my mom's gonna come home
uh at like five or whatever I would
already like get in bed get like a hot
towel
don't feel good something like this so
my mom comes home she's like oh oh you
don't feel good on my knob I think I'm a
fever I'm gonna go to sleep you have
covered 2004. she's like oh no no okay
no it's all right that's fine just just
go to sleep it sucks that you have a
fever okay thank you and then [ __ ]
like 20 minutes later ding dong oh my
god oh no [ __ ] drop yeah lady's like
hey uh your son's been [ __ ] throwing
food over the wall
over today
and then and then my mom comes she goes
hey wake up I'm like no no I have a
fever
I said no you don't so she she's like we
gotta go and see so she rinsed the
covers off we go over to the Korean
lady's house bread crumbs on your
evidence is everywhere we go in the
backyard there's [ __ ] like bean
sprouts [ __ ] Bean curds [ __ ] all
kinds of [ __ ] when we came back home she
beat the [ __ ] out of me imagine being on
the receiving end
oh it's so nasty it's so [ __ ] nasty
I've never seen a bird eat a bean sprout
to be fair yeah that's true they
wouldn't do that that's true they
wouldn't do that they're Birds I can
divide the three physical punishments
into three different categories that I
got there was
um so there's [ __ ] submission holds
strikes and uh and slams oh UFC Rules
so like an easy one like and all these
all these three things would always kind
of knock me out like I would get knocked
out and then uh one of them was like we
had those like hanging chandeliers made
of shells in the kitchen and then for
some [ __ ] reason I was just staring
at it I was like six I couldn't resist
it and I just had to [ __ ] slap it and
it just made a crazy ass sound and the
next thing I know like I was just
getting picked up and then slammed down
and I just went what it was like a
minute later and my dad like picked me
up and knocked me out oh [ __ ] and then
um and then for submission holds that's
where the sacrificial style came from
yeah that's what the head thing came
from yeah we think it sort of his
dancing but he was already given to it
so he started dancing my dad was pissed
that I was nagging him to like he was
visiting with my aunt and I was like can
we go it's boring you know when your
parents are visiting with relatives and
you have nothing to do so I just kept
nagging him and he was just like wait
hold on wait and he got sick of like
telling me that and then when we got
home he got a belt and tied around my
neck and just went like this holy [ __ ]
and I was just like
I [ __ ] knocked out there too dude
Sean Connery's Bond killed guys with
that I know that's why that's where he
probably got it holy yeah did you uh put
this in your uh college essays or what's
up dude no I got in on the dance [ __ ]
that's what Hitman does dude
that's what code name 47 yeah agent 47.
so that's that's the submission the
strike one's the only one that's
actually kind of funny because the
hardest like my dad's hit me tons of
times but the hardest he ever hit me was
I think I was like in second or third
grade and I think I got scared or some
[ __ ] so I wanted to sleep in his bed and
it was just me and him and we're
sleeping and then like I flail around a
lot when I sleep and I remember I like I
woke up the same time I was flailing and
I felt myself like hit him kind of in
the face and then instantly I just feel
him like get up and he just went and he
socked me back in my face so hard while
I'm facing up in the bed and I just
remember going
and I went oh fine and he [ __ ]
clobbered me while I was like how old
are you somebody called the IRA I was
like seven dude somebody called Herb
Dean
over that like I didn't even mean to do
it and I remember him like super socking
me into the bed whoa so I have a
question too whoa so when you were that
age or like as you got older and you
would tell these stories to like your
friends would anyone else have anything
comparable yeah I think at the time we
did because all my friends are Asian
[ __ ] belt choking though dude that's
until you pass out I got you there
though I don't think my dad ever
believes that I really pass out oh he
thinks like you're faking it like his
fever yeah he thinks he always like
thought that I was faking it and I think
like you know he's just like probably
doesn't remember doing any of these
things yeah yeah for sure they did him
so much
he'll be like which time what are you
talking about quickly as possible
um so yeah not necessarily true because
unfortunately like I'm oh dude I'll
never forget every Sunday we're supposed
to go to the comic book store my dad
right and so I was riding bikes with my
friends and like I didn't remember that
it was even Sunday because it's the
weekend and I was just excited as [ __ ]
and we're all hanging out we're way too
long like by the pond and we would go
down there and just like do stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] why well on this particular
day my dad like what had been waiting
for a while like he'd been waiting for
like 45 minutes and so by the time that
I got home
the like once you walk through the door
and the door closed behind you like you
kind of feel it you know I mean like the
mood shifts and it's like yeah it's like
there's a tense thing that goes to the
air and he was like holy [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] were you right
and then he looks at me like he gives me
this [ __ ] look like he's a little
closer to me than he's like this close
to me as Nick right now and gives me
this look
and he just [ __ ] comes over and comes
to me like super hard
what the [ __ ] man I didn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] kid he's like I didn't want an
[ __ ]
he's like I didn't know he's like I
didn't know where you were
[Laughter]
he's like I was so don't be like our
parents please
[Music]
oh